let me catch you guys up
so last night i found out my nemesis
miles got a macarthur genius grant
just after my ex turned me down for sex
so i got angry i got very drunk
and i went pee-pee on the hospital where
she works the police officer suggested
that i stop
i suggested that he'd pleasure me
sexually he did not
instead he hurt my arm and i went to
jail
[Music]
so that catches you guys up to speed why
do we get back to work on destroying
miles sanity
as you all know this week we are
devoting our attention to the
psychological dismantling of my academic
rival
miles leonard miles happens to be
british he also happens to be
adopted so this week we will practice
and perfect british accents and whoever
is best will call him posing as his
biological birth mother who he's never
met and tell him some sort of
devastating secret
[Music]
any questions this
is my sanctuary
[Music]
that's my
oh
i was kicked out of the bookstore i
tried to explain to the manager that
their
staff pick was feel-good soft-core
nonsense yeah i
happened to gesture with my coffee hand
you know splashed a couple measly drops
on the guy he starts throwing the word
scalded around you have scalded me
and next thing i know this large calf
tyrant has his
troop of baboons forcibly eject me so
new plan
british accents weren't exactly taken
off anyway we will now focus on taking
down
the miles display you will infiltrate
the store by getting jobs there
and changing the staff pick thereby
giving me some semblance of sanctuary in
this
chili dump of a town
okay everyone shut up immediately
today we're starting a new revenge
mission our target
boom hey they
ow go to the principal's office right
now you two you sycophantic minions
according to this gossip column my
nemesis miles is
dating lisa loeb the lisa loeb songbird
sex in glasses meanwhile i have had
zero bangs since moving to this garbage
pile of a town
that's not gonna work for me so new plan
break up miles and lisa loeb
what the hell is going on here
it's parent-teacher day
well welcome to ap bio so i wasn't able
to hit eggleston but i peeped on his
building
and i popped one of the interns pretty
good yeah there's a warrant for my
arrest in new york but guess what
and in new york
okay i'm ready do it okay
i can't i can't damn it sarika
why would no one staple my hand maybe if
he told us why
all right listen you dum-dums plan is to
injure myself badly enough so i can be
admitted to the hospital where my high
school ex
meredith works things were definitely
flirty the last time i saw her
and if i can get her to show her
caretaking side well
that is gonna be my ticket to bang city
doesn't she have a boyfriend i'm sorry
do you guys not look at these uh he's
crossed through he's nothing i'm the one
that's perfect for her don't make me
feel like i'm wasting my time up here
now
who's gonna staple my hand
nope uh-uh shut it down shut it all down
right now whatever biology you're
studying back there it's done
okay back to the miles missions as we
said
this is both i think you'll be pleased
with this
i got a lock of miles as hair boss
and a little child shall lead them
how'd you do this remember when you had
me send him that catfish message
it blossomed into a very complicated
online relationship
wow okay well kudos now i think it's
probably best that you cut off all ties
to this 40-year-old man
forever yeah it's gonna be much easier
after the holidays chief
looks like i underestimated you guys i
mean hell if it takes five minutes of
biology a day to destroy my rival then
maybe it's worth it
all right go ahead and take your seats
yeah all right
so uh what's the next step we find a
murdered body
what damn it that's the next step
that is a very hard next step you luck
into a murdered body presumably before
the police have arrived that's insane
all right take out your phones and start
typing miles leonard pedophile into
google
luck into a murdered body what are you
talking about
you want me to throw away the hair nah
let's go ahead and keep the hair
you know this is toledo after all it's
probably dead body somewhere in this
room i don't care
i'll just pop one of these advil pms and
go to sleep
let's see if we can make today become
tomorrow
you said there's no greater pick-me-up
than taking down someone who's wronged
you
but now you're just gonna sit there and
do nothing yep
all right what is one quality that miles
has
that mr griffin doesn't he's
british which means he can get
deported and what's the number one
reason people get deported
exotic animal smuggling all we have to
do is get illegal exotic animals
put them in his house call the feds and
boom
he's deported
where would you get the animals yo my
sketchy neighbor breeds snakes
yeah he's always trying to sell his
python eggs
hmm you know guys there there could be
something to this
look at that while we're on takedowns
i'm putting that stanford dean on the
list freaking hyena
oh if we're making a list can we put my
karate teacher on it
what he laughed when i fell down my
roundhouse kick
god does sound sucky the dictator at cvs
won't let me buy more than seven
lighters
sure let's get him he's toast
this should go without saying but uh
we're back to be in a no bio zone i
should go ahead and toss that puppy in
here sarika
let's go yep
there we go
yeah all right now we're cooking
what else we got my grandpa insists on
cutting my hair
oh that's no good my dentist is making
me get braces but
i don't think i need them
keep them coming who else coach novak
for making me do push-ups the lunch lady
with a beard
denzel washington but also just to meet
him denzel the kid in the cafeteria who
keeps flicking my nipples
you